ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الاسبانيه ان السفاره
الامريكيه في مدريد تلقى طردا ممثلا
للطرود الخمسه المنغمه المرسله في وقت
سابق لمؤسسات اسبانيه اخرى وكانت الشرطه
الاسبانيه قد اكدت ان رئيس الحكومه كان
اول اهداف الرسائل المتفجره على خلفيه حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وقال نائب وزير
الداخليه ان التحقيق لا يزال في المراحل
الاولى ومن المبكر معرفه الجهه المسؤوله
واضاف المسؤول الاسباني في مؤتمر الصحفي
انه ليس هناك اسباب كافيه حتى الان ليرفع
مستوى التهديد الارهابي مضيفا الى ان
المؤشرات الاوليه تشير الى ان الطرود
المرغمه قد ارسلت من داخل الاراضي
الاسبانيه
لدكتور
بعد الاعلان عن اكتشاف رسائل مفخفه عده
اخرها رسالتان منغمتان ارسلت احداهما الى
وزاره الدفاع والاخرى الى مركز الاقمار
الصناعيه التابع لقاعده طورخن الجويه
الواقعه بضواحي العاصمه مدريد